I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense tell me what my world looks like
to make me go Danica you're on the right
path yeah so so when they're I know I
mean I've been doing this long enough to
tell you that nobody changes until they
change their energy right and when you
change your energy you change your life
it's the way it is so so when there's no
when you stop using your enemy to
reaffirm your addiction to hatred when
you stop using your best friend to
reaffirm your addiction to suffering
when you stop using your Facebook to
reaffirm your addiction to insecurity
you stop that whole process and you
start going inward and you're no longer
relying on those outer things that
create those emotions and you start
creating those inner emotional states
you start changing your energy now
whatever is no longer a vibrational
match between you and that past present
reality is going to fall away they're
just gonna spiral out because there's
you're no longer putting your attention
on them in other words the stronger the
emotion you feel was some problem in
your life the more you give it your
attention where you place your attention
is where you place your energy your
giving you a power away your life force
your energy to heal to that person or
that problem lower the volumes of that
emotion you take your attention off that
person you're calling energy back to you
yeah and you're building your own
electromagnetic field we've seen the
evidence of that many events because
people start overcoming themselves the
first day not always but the energy of
the room will drop why because they're
drawing from the field to build their
own field now when they build their own
field the next day and the fields start
interfering with the people next to them
with the energy in the room just keeps
going up alright so now there's no
longer a vibrational match between you
and your coworker you and your job you
and your boss be prepared because that
old gnomes thing is going to fall away
because you're no longer emotionally and
energetically connected to it so then
when we you get in that state it's not a
time to try to put it back together
because at the same time these things
are unraveling and they're moving
towards chaos and chaos is just
unpredictable order right it's novelty
the newness of an experience that you
can't predict is chaos if you put apply
the formula and all
potentials in the quantum field exists
as electromagnetic potentials they are
possibilities so now you're gonna
combine a clear intention with an
elevated motion the thought being
electrical charge the feeling of being
the magnetic charge you begin to open
your heart it begins to produce that
broad field you lay the thought of a new
future into there now you're changing
your energy when they begin to
synchronize coherently your brain and
heart you got a strong Wi-Fi signal
because now you're putting out a very
laser coherent signal when there's a
synchronization between your energy and
that potential that exists in the future
but it really exists in the present
moment because that's where they exist
in the quantum now you start to see
synchronicities in your life because
you're synchronized to a future and they
come as you know Wow cool and those are
breadcrumbs from the fields like keep
going keep going you're on you're on to
something yeah so the problem is that
people they do it and then they get up
and then they get react and traffic or
they get frustrated and they start
feeling the emotions they start feeling
the emotions of their past and you know
what happens they just disconnected from
the energy of their future and they're
back to the energy the best don't expect
anything to change in your life in fact
expect more reasons to be frustrated but
if you catch yourself yeah you take a
breath to get back at the brain and
heart coherence you tune back in well
you're not gonna go unconscious that's a
victory so then so then the key then is
to be able to keep synchronizing to the
point where it begins to become familiar
and the word meditation means to become
familiar with so now you're in a new
familiar state of being and you're and
people say ah you know I'm really not
doing anything you know of course you're
doing the work you're becoming familiar
with a new set of thoughts new set of
intentions and instead of emotions or
hearts opening more your immune systems
up regulating your genes are upregulated
your brain and heart or more coherence
your energy field is bigger you feel
connected more all these things that you
know you're changing programs you start
seeing those things taking place in your
life you're going to want to do this
right it's not gonna be it's not gonna
be effort how's that live by the
hormones of stress the hormones of
stress
caused us to draw from this field and
turn it into chemistry heightens our
senses we become materialists we now are
our focus on the cause now when we
create reality now we're living in
three-dimensional reality the way we do
it is we got to drag our body through
space from one point of consciousness
where I am to my future when dreams
another point of consciousness and
that's gonna take time
so creating from three-dimensional
reality takes time
[Music]